this federal announcement comes a week
after the clark county school district
voted to allow a vaccine mandate for its
staff now many are wondering how ccsd
will follow suit sasha loftis has the
very latest after tonight's regular
board meeting
motion passed one week after ccsd
trustees voted in favor of a staff
vaccine mandate please escort her out
parents and teachers shared their
frustration during thursday's regular
board meeting implementing a mandate is
upsetting frustrating and repelling
employees current and potential per the
board's decision superintendent dr jesus
jarrah has the power to require covid 19
immunization for all employees i am so
proud
of the board of trustees for their
decision no official plan is in place
for the district yet so we asked dr jara
if he will follow federal vaccine rules
announced thursday requiring employees
in workplaces of at least 100 people to
get vaccinated or test for the virus
weekly i thank the president for
continuing on on his commitment and
congress
on their commitment to make sure that
our children are in classrooms though he
wouldn't concretely say what's in store
the superintendent also praised
president biden's push for covet 19
safety measures in schools you have
angered more people than you could
imagine still those here said they're
unhappy and they won't stop fighting
until things change i respectfully ask
you to reconsider your decision of last
week sasha loftis 8 news now